Professor Shelly Kagan:
Last time, I distinguished
between two ways in which
thinking about the facts about
the nature of death could
influence our behavior.
On the one hand,
it could give us reasons to
behave or respond differently,
and on the other hand it could
merely cause us to behave
differently.
Insofar as it just happens to
be some fact about human
psychology that we behave this
way or that way,
perhaps the appropriate way to
deal with the facts of death
would be to simply disregard
them.
I'm inclined to believe,
however, that there are ways in
which thinking about the facts
would not merely cause us to
behave one way rather than
another but give us
reason to behave one way
rather than another.
And that's the question that I
want to then explore from here
on out.
In what circumstances,
or in what ways,
should we behave one way rather
than another?
So, I'm not merely going to
draw on facts about how,
as it happens,
we behave.
It could be that if you dwelled
upon the facts about death,
you would scream interminably
until the moment you
died--taking a tip from Tolstoy.
But that doesn't itself show
that that's an appropriate
response;
that might just be a mere
causal fact about how we're
built.
The question I want to ask is,
how is it appropriate,
in what ways is there reason,
to react one way rather than
another?
Now as I say,
the thought seems very
compelling for most of us that
there are ways in which it makes
sense for the facts about death
to influence how we live,
what our attitudes are,
what are emotions are.
Kafka, for example,
said the meaning of life is the
fact that it ends.
Nice little cryptic saying,
as is typical of Kafka.
But the suggestion,
I suppose, is a fairly common
one, that it's something deep
about how we should live,
that we're going to die,
that our life will come to an
end.
And the question we want to
then explore is how should the
fact, how should recognizing the
fact, that we're going to die,
influence how we live?
How should we respond to that
fact?
Now actually,
the very first kind of
behavior, quote/unquote
behavior, that I want us to
think about perhaps isn't
strictly speaking a form of
behavior at all.
I rather have in mind our
emotional response,
because indeed one of the most
common reactions to death,
I suppose, is fear of
death.
Indeed, fear may in many cases
be too weak a term--an extremely
strong form of fear--terror of
death is,
I suppose, a very common
emotional response to death.
And what I want to do next is
have us ask ourselves,
well, is fear of death a
rationally appropriate response?
Now, the crucial word here is
"appropriate."
I don't want to deny at all
what I take to be the empirical
fact that many people are afraid
of death.
How common a reaction that is,
and how strong the fear is,
I suppose that would be
something for psychologists or
sociologists to study.
And I'm not interested in that
question.
I take it that fear of death is
very common.
I want to know,
is fear of death an
appropriate, a reasonable
emotion?
Now, in raising that question,
I'm obviously presupposing the
larger philosophical thesis that
it makes sense to talk about
emotions as being appropriate or
inappropriate.
We can ask not only what
emotions does somebody have,
but we can also ask what
emotions should they
have?
Now, this point perhaps isn't
an obvious one,
so maybe it's worth dwelling on
for a moment or two,
before we turn to fear of death
per se.
What's another example of an
emotion that's got some
appropriateness conditions?
So, in a moment I'll turn to
asking, what are the conditions
under which it's appropriate to
be afraid of something?--but to
make the more general point,
look, take something like pride;
pride's an emotion.
Under what conditions does it
make sense to be proud of
something?
Well, I suppose at least two
conditions jump out.
First of all,
the thing that you're proud of
has to be some kind of
accomplishment.
If you were to say to me right
now, "I'm really proud of the
fact that I'm breathing,"
I'd look at you in a
noncomprehending fashion because
it doesn't seem to me that
breathing is difficult in any
way,
doesn't count as an
accomplishment,
and as such I can't understand
how or why you would be proud of
the fact that you're breathing.
Now, maybe if you suffered from
asthma and you had to have gone
through excruciating physical
therapy in order to learn how to
use your lungs after some
accident or something;
maybe if we told a story like
that we could see how breathing
naturally and normally would be
an accomplishment,
something to be proud of.
But for all of us,
I presume, it's not an
accomplishment;
hence it's not something that
it's appropriate to be proud of.
Even if we've got an
accomplishment,
that may not be enough.
For something to be something
that it makes sense for you to
be proud of it,
it's got to be in some way an
accomplishment that reflects
well on you.
Now, the most straightforward
cases are cases where it's
your accomplishment,
and the reason that pride makes
sense is because you're the one
who did this difficult thing.
So, you got an A on your
philosophy paper and you tell me
that you're proud and I
understand that;
getting an A on a philosophy
paper is an accomplishment,
and if you wrote the paper then
I understand why you're proud.
Of course, if what you did was
go on the Internet and go to one
of those sites where you pay
money and somebody else writes
an A paper for you,
well, I understand why maybe
they should be proud that
they've written a great
philosophy paper,
but I don't see how this
reflects especially positively
upon you.
So again, there's a kind of
appropriateness condition for
pride, where the object or the
event or the activity that
you're proud of,
or the feature,
has to somehow reflect on you.
Now, that's not to say that
it's got to be your
accomplishment,
at least not in any
straightforward,
narrow sense.
It makes sense,
for example,
to be proud of your children's
accomplishments because there's
the right kind of connection
between you and your children.
So, in some sense it's
connected to you.
And we can have cases where we
wonder about whether or not the
connection is tight enough or
what exactly the nature of the
connection has to be.
Perhaps as an American you took
pride when the Americans win
some event at the Olympics or
the Tour de France or what have
you,
and you say to yourself,
"well look, I didn't ride the
bicycle but for all that I'm an
American and an American won,
I'm proud."
And that makes sense;
we can understand how you think
the connection there is tight
enough.
On the other hand if you say,
"look, the Germans won the
event in the Olympics and I'm
really proud,"
and I ask, well,
are you yourself German,
do you have German heritage,
did you contribute to the
German Olympics support team?
If none of that's true,
then again the appropriateness
condition doesn't seem to be
satisfied.
It doesn't make sense to
be proud.
All right, look,
we could spend more time
worrying about the conditions
under which it makes sense to
feel pride.
But of course that's not really
my purpose here.
My purpose of bringing that in
was just to try to make good on
the thought that emotions do
have requirements;
not necessarily requirements
for what you have to have in
place in order to feel
the emotion.
It's a harder question whether
all these things need to be in
place in order to feel the
emotion.
But at least these things need
to be in place in order for it
to make sense for you to
have the emotion,
in order for it to be rational
or reasonable to feel the
emotion, in order for that
emotional response to be an
appropriate response to your
circumstances or situation.
So, let's ask ourselves,
then, what are the
appropriateness conditions for
fear?
Because armed with that set of
conditions, we'll then be able
to go on and ask,
is it appropriate to feel fear
of death?
Now, three conditions come to
mind when I think about this
question, when I've thought
about this question over the
years.
The first is this--and I
suppose this first one's going
to be fairly uncontroversial--in
order to be afraid of
something--even though I slipped
in this,
to talk about what you need to
have in order to feel
fear, what I really mean is in
order for it to make
sense to feel fear--the
thing that you're afraid of has
to be bad.
If somebody were to say to me,
"I'm afraid that after class
somebody's going to give me an
ice cream cone",
again I'd look at them in
noncomprehension.
I'd say, "Why are you afraid of
that?
How could it make any sense to
be afraid?"
And again, it's not that
somebody couldn't give you an
answer.
They'd say, "Oh I'm trying to
lose weight but I'm so weak and
if they give me an ice cream
cone then I'll just eat it and
that'll ruin my diet for the
week,"
well, then I'd understand.
From that point of view an ice
cream cone is a bad thing and so
that first condition on fear
would be satisfied.
But if you don't have a story
like that, if you're like most
of us, most of the time,
and an ice cream cone's a
pretty good thing,
a source of some passing but at
least genuine pleasure,
then you say,
"How can you be afraid of
having or getting or eating an
ice cream cone?"
It doesn't make sense.
To be afraid of something,
it's got to be bad.
It's one of the reasons why we
sometimes look askance at people
who have various kinds of
phobias--fear of spiders or fear
of dust or what have you,
fear of bunnies--and you think,
how does this make any sense?
It's this cute little bunny;
it's not dangerous.
And maybe there are poisonous
spiders, but most of the spiders
we run across here in
Connecticut are not poisonous.
Fear of spiders doesn't seem
appropriate.
It's not that people can't
have this kind of
emotional reaction,
it's that it doesn't make
sense.
Maybe it's another matter if
you live in Australia,
where there's poisonous snakes
and spiders and other insects
everyplace.
All right.
So, condition number one:
Fear requires something bad,
as the object of your fear.
I can fear getting a migraine,
if I'm subject to migraines.
I can't fear the pleasure of
looking at a beautiful sunset.
That's condition number
one--bad object,
something harmful.
Condition number two is,
there's got to be a
nonnegligible chance of the bad
state of affairs happening,
of the bad object coming to
you.
It's not enough that it's a
logical possibility for fear to
be a reasonable reaction.
There's nothing logically
inconsistent or logically
incoherent about the possibility
that I will face my death by
being ripped to pieces by
Siberian tigers.
It's not as though that's an
inconsistent state of affairs.
It's certainly logically
possible, but it's so unlikely,
it's so negligibly small a
chance,
that if anybody here is afraid
that they'll be ripped to pieces
by tigers, then I can only say
the fear doesn't make any sense,
it's not appropriate.
Again, we can tell special
stories where that might be
different.
Suppose you tell me that,
oh, when you're not a student,
your work study program,
what you do is,
you work as an animal trainer,
or you're planning to work in
the circus where you'll be
training tigers,
then I'll say,
all right, now I suppose
there's a nonnegligible chance
you'll be mauled and killed by
tigers.
I understand it.
But for the rest of us,
I suppose, the chance of being
killed by tigers is,
well, it's not literally zero,
but it's close to zero,
it's negligible.
And so, fear of being eaten by
tigers or mauled to death by
tigers doesn't make any sense.
And once you get the point,
of course, it would be easy to
talk about a variety of other
things that the chances are so
small--fear of being kidnapped
by space creatures from Alpha
Centauri,
where I'll be taken back to the
lab and they'll prod me before
they dissect me alive without
anesthetic.
Yes, I suppose there's some
possibility of that.
It's not logically impossible.
But again it's so vanishingly
small a chance,
and anybody who actually is
afraid of that,
the appropriate thing for us to
say is that their fear is not
appropriate.
All right, so you need to have
a chance of the bad thing,
and it's got to be a large
enough chance.
And I suppose again there would
be room for us to argue about
how large a chance is large
enough,
but when you have vanishingly
small chances then the fear
doesn't make any sense.
That's condition number two.
Condition number three,
I think, is somewhat more
controversial,
but for all that it still seems
correct to me,
and that's this.
We need to have a certain
amount of uncertainty in order
to have fear be appropriate.
You need to have some--it's not
clear how much--but at least
some significant amount of
uncertainty about whether the
bad thing will occur,
and/or how bad the bad thing
will be.
To see the point,
to see the relevance of this
third condition,
imagine that a bad thing was
going to happen to you with a
nonnegligible chance.
Indeed, far from being so small
that it's virtually not worth
even considering,
imagine that it's guaranteed
that the bad thing is going to
happen.
So, there's a bad thing that's
going to happen,
and you know precisely how bad
it is.
So you've got certainty with
regard to the fact that the bad
thing is going to happen,
and certainly with regard to
the size of the bad thing.
I put it to you that in
circumstances like that,
fear is not an appropriate
emotional response.
Suppose that what happens is
this.
Every day you come to school,
to the office,
whatever it is,
and you bring a bagged lunch,
and you put it in the office
refrigerator.
And you include,
along with your lunch,
a dessert;
let's say a cookie.
And every day at one o'clock,
when you go to grab your lunch
out of the refrigerator,
you look inside and you see
somebody has stolen your cookie.
Well, it's a bad thing;
it's not the worst thing in the
world, but it's a bad thing to
have somebody steal your cookie.
And furthermore,
this is more than a negligible
chance.
So, we've got condition one,
condition two in place--bad
thing and a nonnegligible chance
of it happening.
In fact, not only is it not a
negligible chance that it's
happening--guaranteed,
it happens day after day after
day after day.
Bad thing, guaranteed.
And you know precisely how bad
it is.
I put it to you,
fear in that case doesn't make
any sense.
Mind you, there are other
negative emotions that probably
make sense, like anger and
resentment.
Who does this thief,
whoever it is,
think that he or she is,
to be stealing your cookie?
They don't have the right to do
that!
You can be angry,
you can be resentful.
You can be sad that you don't
have a dessert,
day after day after day.
But you can't be afraid,
because there's nothing here
that it makes sense for you to
be afraid of.
Again, being a little sloppy,
maybe you are afraid,
but if so, fear doesn't make
sense,
when you know for a certainty
that the bad thing is coming and
how bad it is.
Suppose that the thief strikes
at random, taking different
people's desserts from different
bags at different times of the
week,
and you never know who he or
she is going to steal from.
Then you might be afraid that
you'll be the person whose
cookie got stolen.
Or if cookie seems to you too
silly an example,
imagine that what happens is
somebody breaks into dorm rooms.
There's been a thief going
around various dorms on campus
and stealing the computer from
the dorm room.
Well there, fear makes sense;
you're afraid that they'll
steal your computer.
Bad thing, nonnegligible
chance, and lack of certainty.
On the other hand,
suppose what happens is,
this is one of those thieves
like you always have in the
movies,
where he's such a master thief,
or she's such a master thief,
that they take pride in their
work,
and so they announce it.
They take out an ad in the
Yale Daily News and they
say, "On Wednesday,
April 27^(th),
I shall steal the computer from
so-and-so's room."
And it doesn't matter what
precautions you take,
something always happens,
and that person's computer gets
stolen.
Well, again,
you could be angry,
you can be pissed,
you can be annoyed,
you can feel stupid that you
didn't take adequate
precautions.
But when the ad appears,
with your name,
and that date,
and all year the thief has
always carried through on the
announced theft,
I put it to you,
fear doesn't make any sense,
because if you know exactly
what the size of the harm is
going to be,
and you're guaranteed that the
harm is coming,
fear is no longer appropriate.
Suppose that I have a little
torture machine,
a little pain generator,
where I put your hand down and
I hook it up to the electrodes
and I crank the dial and I pull
the switch,
and you feel an electric shock.
It makes sense to feel fear
what the next shock is going to
feel like, if the shocks vary in
their intensity.
But if the machine's only got
one setting, on and off,
and all the shocks feel exactly
the same,
and I've done it for you,
"so look, okay,
let me show you what it feels
like; it feels like that."
Oh, not comfortable.
Let me show you what it feels
like, it feels like that;
over and over, 5,6, 7,8 times;
we're doing some sort of weird
psychology experiment here.
Well, you know exactly that
it's coming, you know exactly
what it's going to feel like.
Fear, I put it to you,
doesn't make any sense.
Suppose the experiment's over
now, and you think--you've
gotten your ten dollars and I
refuse to let you go and I say,
"I'm going to do it one more
time, no worse than before."
Well, you might not believe me
and that might introduce the
element of uncertainty and then
perhaps fear would be
appropriate.
But if you believe me that one
more pain exactly like the ones
you felt before is coming,
fear--anger makes sense,
resentment makes sense,
sadness that you're going to
feel this pain perhaps makes
sense--but fear doesn't make
sense.
So, three conditions.
You need to have it's something
bad.
You need to have on the one
hand nonnegligible chance that
the bad thing's going to happen,
and you have to have a lack of
certainty.
If you've got certainty as to
the nature of the bad and
certainty that it's coming,
then fear doesn't make sense.
One of the points probably
worth mentioning in
passing--even when fear does
make sense,
there's a kind of
proportionality condition that
we need to keep in mind as well.
Even if there's a nonnegligible
chance of the harm coming,
and so fear is appropriate,
it doesn't make fear
appropriate if it's obsessive
fear, horrendous fear,
tremendous fear.
Maybe some mild concern is all
that's appropriate if the
chances are small.
Similarly, the amount of fear
needs to be proportioned to the
size of the bad.
That's perhaps why the cookie
example, you might think a lot
of fear there's not appropriate
because even if it comes,
how bad is it?
Loss of a cookie.
All right, so there are some
conditions that need to be met
before fear is appropriate at
all,
and on the other hand even when
fear is appropriate,
it's still legitimate to ask,
how much fear is appropriate?
So, armed with all of this,
let's now turn to the question,
is fear of death appropriate,
and if so, how much?
And immediately we see we need
to draw some distinctions.
Well, what are we supposedly
being afraid of when we are
afraid of death?
And two or perhaps three things
need to be distinguished.
The first thing you might worry
about is the process of dying.
Some people find that the
actual process at the end of
their life is a painful and
unpleasant one.
Yes, I've given the example of
being mauled to death by tigers
or eaten alive by tigers.
Well, I imagine that would be a
pretty unpleasant way to die.
And so insofar as there is some
nonnegligible chance that you
will die a painful death,
then I suppose there's some
room for some--an appropriate
amount--of fear.
Of course, we then have to ask,
well, what is the chance that
you'll die painfully?
I've already indicated for
people in this room I rather
imagine the chance of being
mauled to death by tigers is
vanishingly small.
So, I think,
no fear of that form of painful
death is appropriate.
And for that matter,
I've got to suggest that I
suspect that fear of dying
through a painful operation by
the aliens from Alpha Centauri
is not appropriate either.
Still, the sad fact of the
matter is that there are people
in the world who do suffer
painful deaths,
in particular,
of course, because the number
of diseases that might kill us
off in their final stages are
sometimes painful.
Now, one of the interesting
facts is that we could of course
minimize or eliminate the pain
by giving people adequate pain
medication.
And so, it comes as a rather
unpleasant bit of news that most
hospitals do not provide
adequate pain medication,
in many, many instances,
at the end of life.
Why?
That's a whole other
complicated question.
But I suppose if somebody were
to say to me that--look,
I read the newspaper,
there are studies done
periodically about whether or
not there's adequate pain
medication at the end of life
and the studies suggest,
year after year,
that no, we still don't in
general provide adequate pain
medication.
If you were to say to me,
"In light of that I've got some
fear that this may happen to
me," well, I'd understand that.
Again, if you said to me,
"I can't sleep for fear that
this is going to happen to me,"
I'd want to say,
well, that sort of fear strikes
me as disproportionate.
But at any rate,
I suppose that when people say
that they're afraid of death,
although some of them,
in some moments,
might have in mind,
what they mean is that they're
afraid of the process of dying,
I take it that that's not
actually the central fear that
people mean to be expressing.
People mean to suggest that
they're afraid of death itself,
they're afraid of being
dead.
And with regard to that,
I want to suggest,
I don't actually think the
relevant conditions are
satisfied.
Look, let's think about what
they were again.
There was a certain amount of
uncertainty.
Well, of course,
with regard to being dead
there's no uncertainty at all.
You're guaranteed that you're
going to die.
And indeed, condition number
one, that the bad thing--for
fear to make sense the object of
my fear has to be a bad thing.
Well, let's ask ourselves,
is being dead intrinsically a
bad thing?
It doesn't seem to me that it
is.
Of course, this all presupposes
the positions about the nature
of death that I argued for in
the first half of this semester.
There's nothing mysterious or
unknown about death.
Look, suppose you thought there
was.
Suppose you believe in the
afterlife, or at least the
possibility of an afterlife,
and you're worried that you
might go to hell.
Well, then fear makes some
sense.
If there's a possibility,
nonnegligible in your mind,
that there'll be a painful
experience after you die--not
guaranteed--if you're a bad
enough sinner so that you're
certain you're going to hell,
then again I think condition
number three isn't satisfied.
But if like most of us you
wouldn't know if you were a bad
enough sinner or not,
and so there's some
nonnegligible chance of this bad
thing, without certainly,
well, somebody like that who
says they're afraid of being
dead, for fear that they might
find themselves in hell,
at least I understand that.
But on the physicalist picture
where death is the end,
where when your body decays
there's no experience at all,
then it seems to me that the
first condition on fear isn't
satisfied.
The badness of death after all,
according to the deprivation
account, is the mere absence of
a good.
And it seems to me the mere
absence of a good is not the
right kind of thing to be afraid
of.
Suppose I give you an ice cream
cone, and you like it.
You wish you could have a
second ice cream cone.
But I don't have a second ice
cream cone to share with you.
So you know that after the
first ice cream cone is over,
you won't have a second ice
cream cone.
That's a pity,
that's a lack of something
good.
And now you're telling me,
"I'm afraid;
I'm afraid of the fact that
there will be this period after
the first ice cream cone is done
in which I'm not getting a
second ice cream cone.
I'm afraid because of the
badness of deprivation of ice
cream."
I say to you,
deprivations per se are not the
kind of thing to be afraid of;
they're not bad in the right
kind of way.
So, if death is bad only or
most centrally insofar as it's a
deprivation of the good things
in life, there's nothing bad
there to be afraid of.
Well, that doesn't mean there
isn't anything here in the
neighborhood.
After all, we have to worry not
just about the fact that we're
going to die,
we have to worry about when
we're going to die.
We might be certain that death
is going to come,
but we're not certain that
death is going to come a long
time from now,
as opposed to soon.
So, perhaps the relevant thing
to be afraid of is the
possibility that you'll die
soon.
Consider an analogy.
Suppose that you're at a party,
it's a great party,
you wish you could stay and
stay and stay,
but this is taking place back
in high school,
and what's going to happen is
your mother is going to call at
a certain point and tell you
it's time to go home.
Now, let's just imagine there's
nothing bad about being at home;
it's neutral.
You just wish you could stay
but you know you can't.
If you know the call is going
to come at midnight,
guaranteed, then there's
nothing to be afraid of.
You might resent the fact that
your mother is going to call you
at midnight,
be annoyed at the fact that she
won't let you stay out till one
o'clock like your other friends,
but there's nothing to be
afraid of.
There, it's 11 o'clock and
you're saying,
"I'm terrified of the fact that
the call's going to come at
midnight;
I know it's going to come."
See, fear there doesn't make
sense, because it doesn't have
the relevant degree of
uncertainty.
You know exactly what's coming
and you know for a certainty
that it's coming;
fear isn't appropriate.
Well, suppose instead of what
happens is a guarantee that your
mother's going to call at
midnight,
what we've got is your mother's
going to call sometime between
11 and 1.
Now, some fear makes sense.
Most of the time she calls
around 12,12:30;
sometimes she calls at 1 for
parties;
occasionally she calls at 11.
You're worried now,
there's a nonnegligible chance
she'll call at 11 rather than
sometime later,
12 or 1 o'clock.
There's a bad thing,
some nonnegligible chance,
and the absence of certainty.
Now some degree of fear makes
sense.
And perhaps that's what we've
got with regard to death.
If so, we might say the crucial
ingredient here,
by virtue of which death is
something that it's appropriate
for us to be afraid of is
because of the unpredictability.
Even if we had variability we
might not have unpredictability.
That's a point that we touched
upon previously.
It's the unpredictability that
leaves you in a position of not
knowing whether death will come
soon, or death will come late.
Will you die at 20,
will you die at 50,
will you die at 80,
or will you die at 100?
It seems to me that if it
weren't for the
unpredictability,
fear of death wouldn't make any
sense at all.
Given that we do have
unpredictability,
some fear of death might make
sense;
although again it's important
to be clear about what it is
that it makes sense to be afraid
of.
It's not being dead per se.
I remain of the opinion that
being dead per se is not the
sort of thing it makes sense to
be afraid of,
once you've concluded that
death is the end.
The only thing that it might
make some sense to be afraid of
is that you might die too
soon--earlier rather than later.
Of course, having noted that
point, we then have to ask,
well how much fear is
appropriate?
How great is the chance that
you'll die too soon?
Your fear needs to be
proportioned to the likelihood.
How likely is it that you will
die in the next year,
or five years,
or for that matter 10 or 20
years?
The fact of the matter is for
most of you, almost all of you,
the chances are very unlikely
indeed;
not quite negligible,
but rather small.
For a healthy 20-year-old,
for example,
the chances of dying in the
next five or ten years are
extremely small,
in which case even if some
slight fear might be called for,
no significant amount of fear
seems called for.
So, if somebody were to say to
me, "look, the facts about death
are so overwhelming that I'm
terrified of death,"
all I can say in response is
not, that I don't believe you,
but for all that it seems to me
terror of death is not an
appropriate response.
It doesn't make sense given the
facts.
Now, having said that,
that doesn't mean that there
may not be some other emotion,
some other negative emotion
that is appropriate.
Fear of death strikes me as,
for the most part,
overblown;
it's widespread,
I suppose, but for the most
part inappropriate.
But that doesn't mean that--As
I suggested before in working
through some of these examples,
sometimes anger makes sense;
sometimes resentment makes
sense;
sorrow, regret,
sadness, that may make sense.
So, in having argued that for
the most part fear of death does
not make sense,
I haven't yet given us any
reason to think that there might
not be other emotions,
negative emotions,
that do make sense.
So let's ask.
What about some of those other
possible emotions?
What negative emotion,
if any, does it make sense to
feel about death itself,
the fact that you're going to
die?
Well, of course,
look, it's also worth bearing
in mind, since I've argued that
immortality would be bad,
the fact that you will die is
not actually bad.
It's good because it saves you
from the unpleasant aspect of an
eternal, dreary,
dreadful immortal existence.
Still, we might say,
most of us, almost all of us,
die too soon.
So, what about that?
We die before life has yielded
up all the goods that it could
have given us.
So what is the appropriate
negative emotional response
here?
Or is there one?
I suppose the natural second
suggestion is anger.
You might say,
look, maybe fear isn't right,
isn't appropriate,
but anger.
I'm angry.
I want to shake my fist at the
universe and curse the universe
for giving me only 50 years or
70 years or 80 years even 100
years,
when the world is such a rich,
incredibly fantastic place that
it would take thousands of years
or longer to exhaust what it has
to offer.
So, isn't anger an appropriate
response?
And again, I think the answer
is not so clear that it is,
because, like all the other
emotions, anger itself has
appropriateness conditions.
In order for anger to make
sense, well, here's condition
number one.
It seems to me it's got to be
directed at a person,
it's got to be directed at an
agent,
it's got to be directed at some
thing that had some choice over
what it was doing to you.
So, when your roommate,
whatever it is,
spills coffee on your computer,
destroying the hard drive or
whatever it is,
because they were careless,
even though you told them
previously to be more careful,
anger makes sense.
It's directed at your roommate,
who's a person,
who had some control over what
they were doing.
Your roommate's an agent.
If you want to get angry at
me for the grades that
you receive in this class,
well, at least condition number
one makes sense;
you're directing your anger at
an agent, at an individual
person who has some control over
how I behave,
how they behave.
Condition number two,
I suppose--this may not be all
the conditions,
but at least a second one
is--anger makes sense when,
and only when,
the agent has wronged you,
has treated you in a way that
it was morally inappropriate for
them to teat you.
If your roommate has been doing
things that you don't like,
but they haven't done anything
wrong, anger doesn't make sense.
When you are angry at them,
you are revealing the fact that
you think they've mistreated
you.
Mistreatment requires the
notion of they've behaved toward
you in a way that morally they
shouldn't.
All right, these strike me as
two conditions that need to be
in place in order for anger to
be an appropriate emotional
response.
Of course, again,
we no doubt feel anger in other
cases, although typically when
we're angry at inanimate objects
it's because we've personified
them.
Your paper is due,
you're rushing off to class,
you're about to print it out,
and your computer crashes,
and you get angry at the
computer.
Well, what's going on there,
I suppose, is you've
personified the computer.
You have fallen into the trap,
understandable,
natural, of viewing the
computer as though it was a
person who had deliberately
chosen to fail right now,
letting you down yet again.
And I understand this sort of
behavior;
I do this sort of thing as well.
But of course you can step back.
At least, once your anger has
subsided, you can step back and
say, look, getting angry at your
computer doesn't really make
sense,
because your computer is not a
person;
your computer is not an agent;
your computer didn't have any
choice or control.
Suppose that--take those two
conditions and now ask
ourselves, does it make sense
then to be angry at the fact
that we're going to die?
And I suppose the answer is
going to be, well,
look, who is it,
or what is it that you think is
the cause of our mortality,
or the fact that we only get
our 50 or 80 years?
Here's two crude,
basic alternatives.
You might believe in God,
a kind of classic,
theistic, conception of God,
according to which God is a
person who makes decisions about
what to do.
And God has condemned us to
death.
That's what happens in Genesis,
God punishes Adam and Eve by
making them die.
All right, that's picture
number one.
Picture number two is you just
think there's this impersonal
universe, atoms swirling in the
void,
coming together in various
combinations,
but there's no person behind
the scene controlling all of it.
Let's consider the two
possibilities.
Possibility number one, God.
Well, look, if you've got the
God view, at least we satisfy
the first of our appropriateness
conditions.
We can say, look;
we can say, I'm angry at God
for condemning us to a life
that's short,
that's so inadequate,
relative to the riches that the
world offers us.
That's condition number one.
But what about condition number
two?
Condition number two,
after all, requires that God
has mistreated us in giving us
our 50 or 80 or 100 years.
And is that the case?
Has God wronged us?
Has God treated us in some way
that isn't morally justified?
If not, anger at God,
resentment of God,
wouldn't make sense.
Suppose your roommate comes
into the suite and has a box of
candy, and he gives you a piece
of candy, and you enjoy it.
And he gives you a second piece
of candy and you enjoy it.
And he gives you a third piece
And you ask for a fourth piece
of candy, and he won't give it
you.
Has he wronged you?
Has he treated you immorally?
Does he owe you more
candy?
It's not clear that he or she
does.
But if not, then being
angry--again,
I would certainly understand it
if you got angry,
in the sense that it's a
perfectly common enough
response.
But is anger an
appropriate response to
your roommate for giving you
something, and then not giving
you more?
It's not clear that it
is an appropriate
response.
The appropriate response
actually seems to me to be,
not one of anger,
but gratitude.
Your roommate didn't owe you
any candy at all,
and they gave you four pieces,
or whatever it was,
the number just was.
You might wish you could have
more, you might be sad that you
can't have more,
but anger doesn't seem
appropriate.
God doesn't,
as far as I can see,
owe it to us to give us more
life than what we get.
Well, suppose we don't believe
in the God theory but the
universe theory.
Well then, of course ,even
condition number one isn't
satisfied.
The universe is not a person,
is not an agent,
has no choice and control.
And as such,
again, it just seems to me that
anger then--I can lift my fist
and curse the universe;
of course, what I'm doing then
is, I'm personifying the
universe, treating the universe
as though it was a person that
deliberately decided to make us
die too soon.
But however common that
response might be,
it makes no sense rationally if
the universe is not a person.
It's just atoms swirling,
forming various kinds of
combinations.
Anger at the fact that I'm
going to die,
or die too soon,
doesn't make sense either.
Well, what about sorrow?
Maybe I should just be sad at
the fact that I'm going to die
too soon.
And I think some emotion along
that line does make sense.
The world's a wonderful place.
It would be better to have more
of it.
I'm sad that I don't get more,
that I'm not going to get more.
But having had that thought,
I immediately find myself with
another thought.
Although it's a pity I don't
get more, I'm extremely lucky to
have gotten as much as I get.
The universe is just this
swirling mass of atoms,
forming clumps of various kinds
of things, and dissolving.
Most of those atoms don't get
to be alive at all.
to be a person,
falling in love,
seeing sunsets,
eating ice cream.
It's extraordinarily lucky of
us to be in this select,
fortunate few.
Let me close then with an
expression of this thought.
This is from Kurt Vonnegut's
book, Cat's Cradle.
This is a kind of prayer that
one of the characters in the
novel says--is supposed to
say--at the deathbed.
God made mud.
God got lonesome.
So God said to some of the mud,
"Sit up."
"See all I've made," said God.
"The hills, the sea,
the sky, the stars."
And I, with some of the mud,
had got to sit up and look
around.
Lucky me, lucky mud.
I, mud, sat up and saw what a
nice job God had done.
Nice going God!
Nobody but you could have done
it God!
I certainly couldn't have.
I feel very unimportant
compared to You.
The only way I can feel the
least bit important is to think
of all the mud that didn't even
get to sit up and look around.
I got so much,
and most mud got so little.
Thank you for the honor!
Now mud lies down again and
goes to sleep.
What memories for mud to have!
What interesting other kinds of
sitting-up mud I met!
I loved everything I saw
[Vonnegut 1963].
It seems to me that the right
emotional response isn't fear,
it isn't anger,
it's gratitude that
we're able to be alive at all.